foreign
[Music]
boundless love towards the entire world
a disciplined mind brings happiness
give even if you have only a little
or anger with love
conquer Badness with goodness conquer
meanness with generosity
conquer dishonesty with truth
drop by drop the water pot is filled
likewise the wise man Gathering little
by little fills himself with good
I will not look on another's Bowl intent
of finding fault
a training to be observed
Delight in heedfulness guard well your
thoughts
should you find a wise critic to point
out your faults follow him as you would
a guide to hidden treasure
should a Seeker not find a companion who
is better or equal let him resolutely
pursue a solitary course
in whom there is no sympathy for living
beings know him as an outcast
hatred is Never appeased by hatred in
this world
by non-hatred alone is hatred appeased
this is a law eternal
live with no sense of mind not forming
attachment to experiences
all conditioned things are impermanent
when one sees this with wisdom One turns
away from suffering
ardently due today what must be done who
knows tomorrow death May Come
to support mother and father to cherish
wife and children and to be engaged in
peaceful occupation this is the greatest
blessing
all tremble at violence all fear death
putting oneself in the place of another
one should not kill or cause another to
kill
they blame those who remain silent they
blame those who speak much they blame
those who speak in moderation there is
none in this world who is not blamed
just as the great ocean has one taste
the taste of salt so also this teaching
and discipline has one taste the taste
of liberation
if with a pure mind a person speaks or
acts happiness follows them like a never
departing shadow
as an elephant in the battlefield
withstands arrows shot from bows all
around even so shall I Endure abuse
the root of suffering is attachment
whatever precious Jewel there is in the
Heavenly worlds there is nothing
comparable to one who is awakened
it is in the nature of things that Joy
arises in a person free from remorse
Purity and impurity depend on oneself no
one can purify another
foreign
ceasing to do evil cultivating the good
purifying the heart this is the teaching
of the Buddhas
understanding is the hardwood of
well-spoken words
[Music]
just as a solid rock is not shaken by
the storm even so the wise are not
affected by Praise or blame
[Music]
we will develop love we will practice it
we will make it both a way and a basis
there is no fear for one whose mind is
not filled with desire
[Music]
whatever is not yours let go of it
you're letting go of it will be for your
long-term happiness and benefit
[Music]
meditate do not delay lest you later
regret it
[Music]
whatever can arise can cease
[Music]
your own self is your master who else
could be with yourself well controlled
you gain a master very hard to find
[Music]
your work is to discover your work and
then with all your heart to give
yourself to it
I do not dispute with the world rather
it is the world that disputes with me
you cannot travel the path until you
have become the path itself
do not dwell in the past do not dream of
the future concentrate the mind on the
present moment
if we could see clearly the miracle of a
single flower our whole life would
change
[Music]
the only real failure in life is not to
be true to the best one knows
foreign
be truthful do not yield to anger give
freely even if you have but little the
gods will bless you
[Music]
the whole secret of existence is to have
no fear never fear what will become of
you depend on no one
only at the moment you reject all help
are you free
[Music]
if anything is worth doing it is worth
doing with all your heart
foreign
victory over yourself not even the gods
can turn it into defeat
[Music]
better than a thousand Hollow words is
one word that brings peace
[Music]
what we think we become
[Music]
if you do not change direction you may
end up where you are heading
nothing can harm you as much as your own
unguarded thoughts
nothing remains without change
one moment can change your day one day
it can change your life one life can
change a world
faith and prayer are invisible but they
make impossible things possible
with mindfulness strive on
if the problem can be solved why worry
if the problem cannot be solved worrying
will not help you solve it
you must love yourself before you love
another by accepting yourself and fully
being who you are your simple presence
can make others happy
[Music]
everything that happens to us is the
result of what we ourselves have thought
said or done we alone are responsible
for our lives
[Music]
love the whole world as a mother loves
her only child
[Music]
health is the greatest gift
contentment is the greatest wealth
it is better to do nothing than to do
what is wrong whatever you do you do to
yourself
[Music]
work out your own salvation do not
depend on others
do not look for a sanctuary in anyone
but yourself
no one saves us but ourselves no one can
and no one may we ourselves must walk
the path
[Music]
if we fail to look after others when
they need help who will look after us
[Music]
one who acts on truth is happy in this
world and Beyond
wear your ego like a loose-fitting
garment
[Music]
when watching after yourself you watch
after others when watching after others
you watch after yourself
the greatest gift is to give people your
Enlightenment to share it
ambition is like love impatient both of
delays and of Rivals
okay
you as much as anybody in the entire
universe deserve your love and affection
[Music]
you propose to speak always ask yourself
is it true is it necessary is it kind
[Music]
of every human being is the author of
his own health or disease
the tongue like a sharp knife kills
without drawing blood
the way is not in the sky it is in the
heart
truly loved yourself you would never
hurt another
every morning we are born again what we
do today is what matters most
nothing ever exists entirely alone
everything is related to everything else
[Music]